so
i got a bunch of questions for you guys
i want to start with congrats on the
movie
i want to go backwards for a second
because i don't think a lot of people
realize that joe
uh one of your first professional gigs i
think was playing flash thompson
in sam raimi's spider-man
uh yeah that was my that was my first
movie
right out of drama school right uh
it's crazy to me uh when you think about
the the comic book genre
and what it was back then and what it is
now um
it and i bring this up because uh
obviously you guys are playing with the
comic book genre and superheroes
um so i have to start with joe what do
you remember about
getting to work with sam raimi back then
and what did it mean to you
i was a huge fan of sam raimi as a
director
um you also have to remember
we started i auditioned for that movie
in 2000 we started shooting in 2001.
so you know we're talking like two
decades ago
that film spider-man was the biggest
film ever attempted
and up to that point the superhero genre
was dominated by or um i shouldn't say
dominated because
when you say dominated you think of like
24 marvel films to choose from
you know and dc and back then it wasn't
that way
what you really had in terms of the
superhero genre was
you had tim burton's two batman movies
you had the crow
um then you've got you could probably
throw blade into that category
and then the first x-men so
um all of those including even tim
burton's batman had this
this feel or this sensibility to it
which was
um you know uh
there was there was there was a lot of
art to it and a lot of story to it
and i think there were some risks that
were taken
with those films and you know spider-man
was really the first film that involved
the superhero that wasn't dressed in all
black leather
and and involved a wider color palette
than basically black and gray
and um you know i think
you know i think that paved the way for
big studio
you know the the studio wave or marvel
taking over and then basically everybody
you know chasing after them to a certain
degree um i think when you
when you you know you get into like a
lineage
of those late 80s tim burton films in
the 90s superhero films i think those
connect more easily to a no the nolan
universe
um someone i think those kind of connect
with those films and i think
at least in my mind when i read the
script for arch enemy archenemy was like
to me it felt like a it felt like a
return
to those 90s superhero movies you know
down and dirty
and um and and really you know talking
about something or
you know uh they were they were really
like a wild ride you didn't know what to
expect from them and i read the script
for arch enemy that's kind of well
what came up for me i know this question
was about sam raimi but there we are
no i want i wanted to tie it together
because the thing
that and listen i think you both know
this but like the superhero genre
is the most popular genre on the planet
and
um it's i mean it's all over the planet
um and so adam i'm curious when you were
getting this project off the ground and
writing were you sort of thinking about
how can i play in the superhero world um
because of the popularity of the genre
or was it just an idea that had been
kicking around
yeah no it's funny it wasn't because of
the popularity in the sense that
i want to jump on something that's doing
well it was
because of the popularity in the sense
that now that people have
a lot of familiarity with the mythology
of superheroes
we can do something new with it right
and so like when you talk about
comic book movies what was spider-man in
terms of comic book movies there's also
comic book movies like ghost world
or american splendor which are based on
comics but
don't have superheroes right but like
have a certain kind of
aesthetic and that and that's something
that i was
really interested in was how can we tell
a story about superheroes
that has a totally different kind of
aesthetic than what we're seeing in
superhero movies
and they were able to do this something
joe and i talked about a lot is that
comic books in the 80s when things like
electra assassin came out or animal man
or you know uh uh the black and white
ninja turtles
yeah i like was like you know a greedy
retelling of like x-men even
yeah they took they they took
superheroes and
completely changed the way the
aesthetics of those stories were told
because they knew their audience
you know had seen the same stories over
and over again and so
i think it was in 2015 i started writing
this movie and i was like now that
people have
in it you know mainstream movie
audiences have
a context for the multiverse and what an
origin story is and
you know all of these ideas in in
superheroes
we don't have to tell that same kind of
story we can apply a completely
different
aesthetic and just bla drop all of these
crazy ideas on people and
expect that they'd be able to catch up
can you guys explain
what the film is about and let's just do
the basic thing for people that are
not familiar yet it's
not not a superhero movie
but it's also not a superhero it's about
a
a man who we meet in a bar he's a
extremely you know degraded down on his
luck kind of
person who is constantly telling
everybody in the neighborhood about
how he used to be a vastly powerful
superhero from another dimension
but here on earth he's he's a drunk who
lives under a bridge
and then he meets a young family a
brother and sister who are in big
trouble with
local gangsters and through meeting them
he's able to tell his story more clearly
and
and fight to sort of redeem who he is
who he sees himself as a hero
uh let's talk a little bit about the
first time you guys met each other
was it um to meet on this project or had
you met
earlier then i guess when did you guys
first meet
adam you came over to my house and
uh to to like read we were going to read
but i had been introduced i knew your
work i'd seen daniel isn't real
um you knew spector vision right or you
you knew and i was very
good friends with with everybody over at
spectrovision i was uh
i was obsessed with mandy i became like
like crazy about mandy and
actually you know i had this streetwear
line death staves and um
i've been in some like real serious
talks about doing some
some new original pieces uh wearable
pieces with uh with the director
panos because models and we became
friends and then i you know
met you know a lot i knew elijah and and
met daniel and lisa and became friends
with all of them and
um lisa slipped me the script
of archenemy to see what i thought
because we had been talking about you
know just doing something together
and she said i have this thing that
might be right for you and um
uh let me know what you think and and
then that
led to adam coming over to my house what
was impressive about meeting joe and
talking to him was
you know on the one hand he obviously
you know i was looking for somebody in
this movie
who you could believe could have been a
superhero you know and joe
looks like superman you clean him up a
little bit more than the
pandemic period he looks like superman
you know and it's incredible but then he
also
as we talked like has this depth of you
know
experience and knowledge about acting
and he has a degree in
theater and you know he's like the
perfect kind of
tennessee williams character you know
that
that kind of an actor like uh you know
like he's a he's a sensitive
[ __ ] up deranged actor trapped in the
body of a beautiful football player
which is what
paul newman is and count on a hot tin
roof right like so that's like the
perfect kind of
person for me to work with on a movie
like this and we really and the fact
that he
is such a huge fan of comic books like
gives us you know we could be like
oh yeah it's like that totally obscure
thing about superman or what like we had
that language
and we had the language of you know
dramatic work and acting
and uh sort of understanding the
emotional story
so that it was just it was good it was a
good fit yeah
and you know when i read the script the
script reminded me of
those scripts in drama school are those
those great
you know whatever those great i don't
know it's like um
if sam shepard wrote a superhero movie
to a certain degree
it'd be some drunken drug addict
living in some slum you know somewhere
under a bridge
who's mumbling on and on about what he
used to be
and at that point it doesn't matter if
he was one or if he wasn't you know for
me the acting challenge is there
and it was really one of those things
that i mean it was one of the weirdest
most out there scripts ever and um i had
100 million questions about it in like
the best way possible and
you know i definitely i wanted to meet
adam and i love daniel
isn't real and i saw what he what he
could do with that
and i thought about um you know that
applied to this movie
and then of course the conversations
that we had about
all of the non-mainstream comic books
that that we loved back in the day and
those what-if stories
and this became a real you know it was
doable like i saw the path it was like
oh we could
we could do this like this could this
could work um
and uh and knows
man with joint forces the thing that i
really
uh dug is that the film has a different
um
visual style than i think people are
going to be expecting you have some
animated sequences um
and it's it's just very distinct style
how did you decide
on the look of the animation um
and wanting to put the animation in yeah
so to me the the style like the style of
a movie is
so crucial that's my job as a director
and and
i want to only ever do things that are
super stylish and really have like a
clear visual identity but that has to
come from
what the emotional story is right so i
i referred to this style to everybody i
was working with as romantic brutalism
that's like how i kept talking about it
and we sort of dug into what that would
mean and what that would look like in it
and it had a certain you know like the
that it's so gritty but also there's all
these beautiful reflections and neon and
that kind of stuff comes from that
and the animation you know the the idea
that we were gonna
tell his story the story of his stories
and his memories
what the [ __ ] is that going to look like
so that it's exciting and cool
and has a level of abstraction but still
communicates something
and a huge reference to me was pink
floyd the wall
the way that they use animation in that
movie it's a story about a
rock star who's losing his mind but this
animation
tells you his dreams and his fantasies
and uh
electra assassin what bilson keviks did
in the 80s
with electro assassin with with his
daredevil book love and war
like that it it's a mix of children's
drawings
and photo realistic pencil work and [ __ ]
glued onto a canvas
and um so those were the two big
influences
that i went in when talking to the
artists and the animators
and then making sure that it had like a
searing color palette
because it's very very it's very
important to me that this is a movie
that like
immerses you into a world and
you know we one thing i said to you joe
at the very beginning i don't know if
you remember this
like i wasn't super into clarity i was
into the clarity of the vision but not
the clarity of like
understanding specific story points and
i said you like your voice when you're
telling the story should be more like
the lead guitar in a slayer song you
know like a guitar solo in
a slayer song where it's not about like
the precision of the melodies it's about
the expression of it
yeah and i think you know you and i we
have like similar film references
and you know i think i remember talking
about
stalker you know the old
the old russian film and and kind of
making something that was um
you know it didn't necessarily have to
answer its own questions
and and i think that um that was a lot
of
fun for me was was this idea that um
you know the character doesn't have
answers and a lot of times he doesn't
know
it's it's foggy and he's bent back and
forth between this
you know or at least in his mind between
these different realities as you kind of
ride this ride
um so you know my job as an actor is to
answer all those questions or at least
know what i'm doing but
you know the real challenge was to you
know make
choices based upon a character who has
who doesn't really know what's going on
or is confused
and um and i think that that's you know
i was excited about the kind of ride
that that could maybe provide
for an audience um because if if i'm not
sure what the answers are and the
character doesn't
isn't sure then you know in a really
wonderful way
um and and that's another thing i love
about this the script too was like it
didn't pander
you know i mean there's moments of it
that are educational talking about lofty
scientific terms but it doesn't you know
it doesn't pander
um you know and that's really true of
the characters
yeah i mean what you know i think one
thing that's cool about the character is
that you're a guy who
is drunk drinking all the time and also
you're talking about how you've
experienced multiple realities in
different dimensions and you've gone
through black holes and so i i think one
thing we were always doing is like
imagining what the mind of that person
would be like i think when we you know
when you look at a character like doctor
strange
it's like how does that guy keep it
together like how do you
you know how do you go through like a
million multiple versions of yourself
getting killed and reborn and not be a
complete
lunatic i think that was part of the
influence on what what the character
would be
on the other side of it too is that the
character you know
isn't a scientist or doesn't come from
the science background so you've got
almost like you know it's it's it's
being filtered out of a layman
if you will um but but it's
it's it's like it's a layman who's been
through
like countless medical operations
explaining to you over the breakfast
table
like how surgery works
and i think that that was that was kind
of because he's been through so much of
it and it's not to say that he was
he even understood it before it happened
to him he's been trying to catch up with
it and so i think that that's you know
there's different grades of people in
the film that have certain amounts of
scientific knowledge and you know it was
kind of interesting finding the balance
for for max
yeah there's there's a great little
moment you know because you're always
talking to hamster who's trying to like
boil it down into this really simplified
archetypical terms right and he's like
did you punch bad guys
like is that that's what you're telling
me right your points bad guys and you
and your line is like i've been through
the cosmic tendrils of time
and you're talking about punching like
it's just like such a disconnect and
like i just i love that sense that
you just you know you're never even
really quite there because it's like you
know
the post trauma of a cosmic superhero
right right right yeah right i
definitely have to bring up uh the fact
that glenn howerton
is basically you don't even realize it's
him in the movie
you know he's so i i when i first saw
him on screen i didn't it took me a
little while to realize that was glenn
um and then you also have paul cheer who
does
his thing which i don't want to reveal
anything about his character but
talk a little bit about getting paul and
glenn in the movie
and glenn's look uh because it is
unique well i think you know clearly
something that i like to do is work with
actors who like have an iconic look and
like an iconic style even like joe and
then
help them deconstruct that into a
character you know into the movie where
they're gonna be a whole
new person and and so with glenn like
you know as a guy who's primarily we
know
as a hysterically funny uh comic
actor you know putting him in a in a
more dramatic role in a more dramatic
movie
and letting him find that part of
himself so he was just excited to like
figure out what kind of crazy look you
know the blonde hair the mustache it's
it's it's an incredible look on him well
listen man how about those little john
stockton
tennis shorts man let's not forget about
that i mean
spoilers that is a climactic moment when
he's sorry when you see
his legs i think i'm helping to sell the
movie right now yeah
yeah no i mean absolutely you do you do
get to see
glenn howerton in tennis shorts it's
basically the climax of the movie to see
that's
amazing um but the thing that
i think a lot of people don't know about
glenn is he's so well known
for his sitcom work but glenn is a
juilliard guy
there's a reason why that guy's so good
at what he does
um but it's great to be able to see him
in you know in other roles i think
because his his depth of knowledge is so
deep and his toolbox is so
so big you know he he's great yeah he's
an actor who's
who's been really successful being funny
because he's a good actor
in general and so he fell into being
hilariously funny for 15 straight years
but give him a chance to be you know
terrifying or menacing and all that and
he could do that too which is
fun and same with paul i mean what's
great about paul is paul is a master of
improvisational
acting so the scene he's in he's more or
less doing the entire script as written
but he's using everything they gave him
he's using
i'm going to spoil too much but he's
using the snakeskin boots they gave him
he's using
the tattoos on his face he's using all
of the pills and alcohol bottles that
they put on
you know it's like he looks around and
he's like what what am i wearing what do
i have what's around me and used
you know something that people kept
saying when we shot that scene was he
used the work of every department
like in this one moment he just brings
together the
set the makeup the the decor you know
and like
and finds a way to incorporate that into
the scene and yeah he has
insane uh his scene is quite good i will
just say it like that
uh you obviously you guys made this you
obviously uh
uh had a finite budget and a finite
schedule
what was the toughest stuff to pull off
with the limited
resources and time that you had
making the movie it was a
it was it was the most brutally
difficult project i've ever done in my
life
the um the time we had the budget that
i mean we felt like we were cursed by a
witch i mean we had
people getting getting sick and suddenly
unable to show up
on days when we had crucial scenes and
figuring out how to like revise the
script or change our
plan move things around i mean it it was
every movie is is a bit of a fire that
you have to deal with in this
this was so rough but i think that the
way that we were able but because we
knew
what the movie was so well we were able
to adapt to it in some ways make it
better like
some something would fall apart and then
joe and i would be like okay well we
can't do any of what we thought we were
going to do
but this character like let's just show
them walking around and trying to do
this thing and trying to do that thing
and that's what we're really trying to
communicate
anyway and from the very start
i realized it's gonna behoove me
to not only prep for what we're shooting
that day
but make sure that i'm prepped with a
whole bunch of other stuff too
you know just in case you know
things went sideways or this didn't work
out the way that we needed to
and we're just going to pick the cameras
up and go move somewhere
and i'm gonna start delivering speeches
i would have delivered in a different
location
but over here or you know we're gonna
try to film that dialogue from a
different angle
you know and and so you know i think
like adam's saying there was a lot of
like really great i mean you say cursed
by a witch but you know i say
you know we were we were just making
lemonade out there all day long
and i think some of the some fantastic
uh some of my favorite parts of the film
came out of
necessity and i think that's that's the
beauty actually of
working on indie films and working at
this budget and the speed
uh with a a filmmaker
of the caliber of adam is that
it means that there's not a lot of
distraction and there's not a lot of
checks and balances in the way of us
pivoting in the moment if we know that
something else is going to work better
and i think that was such a a weapon for
us
for making a film of this size is the
fact that if you have a strong nucleus
you can just pivot you know we were just
pivoting making decisions in the moment
um
you know and and in a lot of ways you
know most ways making the film better
yeah i mean you know it the one of my
biggest influences on this movie was one
car why
right i was like what would it be like
if one car y made a superhero movie what
would that look like and the way he
makes movies
at least you know his first dozen movies
or whatever was he shows up on the day
with the
with the set and the actors and chris
doyle the greatest cinematographer of
all time and goes so what should we do
today
oh look there's a sink let's do a scene
where you're washing your face
you know and i've always been jealous of
that way of working and sometimes we had
such big disasters on set
that i actually got to work that way and
it was great it was and it was me at my
happiest
being like okay here's what we're gonna
do today guys and like it's just
it's so great because the actors know
what they're doing and everybody knows
the style of the movie
and now we can do a thing so i hope this
doesn't seem too vague i don't want
because
i'll never want to say like this is a
scene we wrote on the day and this isn't
because then
people receive the movie the wrong way
but being able to to be so
playful under the incredible stress of
it
is to me like the best way to make a
movie well
one specifically joe you have a lot of
experience uh
doing action you've done action stuff
before and in this movie you have to do
action
um how did your previous work
uh doing action set pieces help this
film because obviously you didn't have
the
resources that you might have on a
bigger movie were you able to you know
facilitate and help because there's some
there's a i don't want to give anything
away because no one has seen it yet
but i'm thinking of like an apartment
scene where you're fighting some people
and it's
brutal and bloody and you obviously are
again
making this on a schedule and a budget
yeah
well um you know i'm no longer
you know i'm no longer the the you know
the baby on the set if you will you know
i'm not
i'm not a freshman anymore um i've been
doing this
you know i've been doing this a couple
decades you talk about spider-man that
was two decades ago
so um that also yeah involves some
action and fighting
you know i think what happens
you know even the bigger the set i'm
still the one who has to do it all
so you know when you know the buck stops
with you
for that um
yeah you know i i want to say i put in
my 10 000 hours of fighting and
shooting and killing people you know and
i think
um on a film like this that's shooting
as quick as this
i don't want to do a second take i want
to nail everything on the first
and so it becomes this dance it becomes
choreography it becomes a way of telling
a story in the moment and
i don't know i think that's something
that that i've always enjoyed
and and um you know like that scene that
you're talking about in the apartment
um yeah i mean
you know i don't know how many times we
can do it again and i don't know how
many costume pieces we have to do it
again
and frankly we don't have time to reset
me
again to do it again so you know
my goal is to come in there and and nail
it like absolutely nail it
in frame the way the gimmicks work
and and so you know um you know i'm
sorry for anyone who tries to talk to me
on a day
or you know while i'm getting ready to
do something like that because i can't
i'm concentrating on like 10 different
variables
that i on that i need to nail in
something that's
you know five seconds fast and it's over
so
um but i enjoy that i like that kind of
pressure it makes me feel like i'm a
tight rub walker or something i'm up
there and there's no net
and you better nail this thing or we're
screwed and we're not going to make our
day
so i i really do like that kind of
pressure i
love working with stuntman you love
working with the choreographers like
seeing you
hang with them it was like you guys are
like a band like you just really click
with that stuff and then all
you know you also have some experience
working on movies where you're like
a swat guy or a gun guy or whatever so
we could i could talk to you as if
you you are the character who knows what
this stuff is and be like no i wouldn't
hold it like this
yeah and i'd be like okay joe's get look
don't tell joe to hold a gun like this
i'll tell you
15 minutes about why it's going to jam
it's very true i'm basically out of time
with you guys but um
i joe i do have to ask you i'm
incredibly excited to see zach
snyder the snyder cut because i i want
to see the
the extended version of all of zack's
movies are
always better from watchmen to bvs to
you name it
it's always better um have you
have you seen anything of the snyder cut
uh
and i have to ask are you doing any
additional photography for it
i knew you're gonna ask me this man and
um
i knew it um well by the way i'm asking
because i'm a legit fan
and i really want to know and yes
so we the fans want to know too i know
and they're going to go crazy and
they're going to come back at me with
whatever i say
so um you know i'll i can't you know
that's if if i was
a part of it that wouldn't be my it
wouldn't be my place to announce
that that would be zack's place
um so you know um
whether or not that's happening you know
that's that is not
that is a that is an answer that
is above my below my nda level or
whatever you want to call it did we just
lie and say that deathstroke appears in
archenemy so the 10 million more people
see it
yeah in the meantime you can go watch
archenemy it's you know you'll see some
similarities
just real quick though have you seen any
extra stuff did zach ever show you like
a longer version or you're going to be
have you seen any of that well look i
mean you know on my social media i
talked about
you know there there was an original
and credit sequence that was altered for
the release of
justice league once batman was canceled
they altered that scene
so here you go i mean it's it's
you know but i i wrote about that on my
social media there's an original scene
that will be
restored to us you know
to what it was originally i'll just stop
it there but um for real uh
uh congrats on the movie and uh
i really always like supporting indie
cinema and this is indie cinema
thank you so much steve thanks steven